what's up everyone this is Anthony
papiano most of you know me as pump
you're listening to off the chain
simply the best podcasting crypto let's
kick this thing off hey guys in this
episode I talked to mark Schneider he's
a nuclear futurist and a leading expert
in emerging Gen for nuclear power he's
got a bachelor's degree in nuclear
engineering technology and has spent 20
years working with advanced small-scale
nuclear reactors within the u.s. naval
nuclear power program basically he's way
smarter than me I really wanted him to
come in and give me an overview on all
things nuclear power how it works why
it's important and where the industry is
going this is a fascinating episode that
I've learned a ton from all right guys
bang bang I've got mark here I'm super
excited to record this episode the
caveat to it all is until about 48 hours
ago I knew absolutely nothing about
nuclear energy I have spent a little bit
of time googling around reading I even
listened to a Department of Energy
podcast yes the Department of Energy has
a podcast and so I've kind of done my
best to to get a base understanding but
I wanted mark to come in and really give
an overview of this power source kind of
how the science works how the reactors
work and then talk through the pros and
cons and what the critiques are on the
responses etc and so thank you so much
for coming here to New York his first
time in New York City to to do this
thanks for having me I appreciate it
it's been fun get finding out the city I
think he actually said to me we were
messaging and he said it's busy yes that
is an understatement all right so let's
get started just with your background
some people understand that perspective
you're coming from you spent 20 years in
the Navy maybe tell us a little about
what you did there and what you've done
since you left the Navy yes yes I did 20
years in the Navy I stopped rated on
Donder I served on three different
submarines and aircraft carriers and
I've seen both the the underwater and
the surface side of the Navy I also work
for an organization called naval
reactors which is kind of the Nuclear
Regulatory Commission version for the
military or for the Navy providing
regulatory oversight and construction
and operation
the reactors and then I have commercial
power experience as well and so that's
kind of my overall general general
background and then in addition you know
a man a very few hobbies and my wife is
a nuclear engineer too so you know I
have the you know the nerdiest
pillow-talk of anyone so you know it's
it's just a lot of fun but you know so
we eat breathe and sleep nuclear my
house that that's awesome
do you guys meet Navy or outside so my
wife worked for the shipyard and we met
on the USS California while she was
under construction we met and her the
instrumentation and control room it's
all the the equipment that controls the
reactor itself so that's where we met
was literally in the room filled with
all the equipment that operates the
reactor for two nuclear engineers that's
like a very romantic place to meet it
was love at first sight alright so let's
get into a little bit you know you have
a very unique background and experience
in terms of not only are you very
well-versed in kind of the regulatory
side and the construction of these
reactors and kind of the oversight but
also having been on aircraft and
submarines you've seen kind of what I'll
call the land-based reactors then also
what's powering some of these military
vehicles and transportation etc how does
nucular work right I think is one of the
things that I always get asked about now
that people know that you're coming on
and I say I don't know right so kind of
what's the best way to describe how
nuclear actually works so this is the
way that it's described amongst the the
super smart nerds that operate these
reactors and I love this because it's
the it's the simplest explanation and
it's the magic Rock gets hot it boils
the water it makes the roundy roundy
which causes the Archy Sparky which is
fascinating and and basically to break
it down in and you know is that you've
got a reactor and what you use you use a
fuel and there's all sorts different
types of fuel and I'm not gonna bore you
with that but it absorbs a neutron it
splits that causes heat to be generated
that heat then used to boil water it
turns a turbine that turbine can either
it can be used to make power in the form
of a commercial plant or it can be used
to
you know drive a propeller on a ship and
then the other thing is that steam for
say an aircraft carrier at least the
older the I say older last one was built
not that long ago but they'll use that
steam to drive a piston that launches
the aircraft off of them got it and so
really what's happening is there's a
reaction that reaction causes heat the
heat boils water water boiling creates
steam that steam is captured and spins
this turbine that you're talking about I
think that generally anyone who spent
some time on like how energy is produced
the idea that hot water creates steam
through a turbine is used not just a
nuclear button other forms of energy as
well good yeah I mean absolutely I mean
and you know it's it's funny because
with the exception of solar they you
basically have a rotating piece of EQ of
equipment that is attached to a
generator that makes sure electricity
and how you rotate that whether it's
like a coal plant that uses the exact
same style of steam plant a exact but
very similar style steam plant to a
nuclear power plant or you can do it
with your oil you know to heat that or
if you say have you know like a diesel
engine or a gas turbine or hydro where
you just have something else that's
causing that rotation you know if you
look at you know you could go out on the
street and you see the big light poles
that's literally just a mini power plant
right there it's just it's using gas to
drive an engine that causes a shaft to
turn this attached to a generator they
you know is making electricity and power
in that light bulb so the same concept
works
it's just that in nuclear you're doing
it on extremely large scales for sure
and in the reaction that's creating the
heat I think is the part that is kind of
a black box to people right and so maybe
describe a little bit about how that
reaction is occurring from that from
natural science of it yeah so the way it
works is that you have you know your
your fuel and I'm just gonna use uranium
235 is where you say what's called your
aim 235 as a fuel for this that uranium
absorbs a neutron and and then it splits
it that's those are the fission products
that's part of the waste we talked about
and this is like a collision right where
basically uranium is sitting there doing
whatever uranium does in kind of its
steady state and then we're taking a
neutron and we're
creating that collision in a reaction
and that's where the heat comes from
yeah absolutely and then what's happened
is is that when that atom splits it
splits into two fission products and
that also will release the number of
neutrons the average for uranium 235 is
about two and a half and now if you can
if you do the math right if I have one
atom takes one - generates two and a
half neutrons
well now you can see you can develop an
unselfie dori an uncontrollable reaction
so we have these things called control
rods or there's other methods to control
the reaction and so it's like a throttle
on your car so we basically want to
control the amount of neutrons they
absorb the neutrons these control rods
do and the neutrons get absorbed by that
so that you have basically every atom of
uranium that splits you have one Neutron
generated to go on to the next uranium
atom okay and so as we take these
neutrons you know create the collision
with the uranium atom and there's that
splitting if this was to happen just out
in the open and not a confined space
could be problematic cuz it's just
uncontrolled in this sense what you're
essentially doing is first you're
putting it all into a controlled area
and then what you're describing is in
that controlled area the science behind
this is you can essentially use that
throttling mechanism to make sure that
every time an atom splits there's only
the creation of one new Neutron on a net
basis right yeah yeah you know that
perfectly got it I'm gonna be a nuclear
engineer by the end of this and so going
back to so that's how nuclear works
today how does that reaction to heat to
steam to the turbine how does this work
inside of like a nuclear power plants
talking on land you know what most
people would think of as like the
large-scale power plants what's
happening in those power plants how do
we go from that kind of one mechanism to
the actual large-scale facility
well I mean you've got a lot of there
they're called fuel assemblies that are
just made up of these little rod lights
that are literally about the thickness
of a large pen and they're like several
feet long at least for us reactors and
they're they're all filled with these
and they're all filled with little
pellets of uranium inside of there and
that that reaction just occurring at a
really large scale you've got a lot of
those reactions occurring throughout the
entire reactor itself and that's
generating that large quantity of heat
and so yeah so that's the basic thing
and then you as far as it causes like a
pressurized water reactor that water
gets really hot it just pumped through
what's called your primary loop into a
steam generator the steam generator
generates steam it pumps it into a or
the steam is sent to a turbine spins the
turbine
it's then cooled using like a lake a
river treated sewage like out at Palo
Verde and then it is condensed back into
water they pumped that water back in so
you have a closed cycle got it and so in
an average u.s. reactor or power plant
how many of those rods are we talking
about that could be at use at any one
time so a 900 megawatt reactor has about
a hundred and sixty fuel assemblies in
it so fuel assemblies are about your 14
to 18 inches square okay and inside of
those fuel assemblies is a bunch of
different rods that yeah yeah got it
and so is that true like we'll call it
the u.s. design is that true
internationally as well because the
numbers that when I was researching
there's about a hundred active nuclear
power plants today in the United States
international including international
you get to about 400 total globally
right yeah so really about right yeah we
have well 460 globally right now with 56
under construction but so that the u.s.
or the pressurized water and boiling
water reactors that is the that square
assembly is is true I don't know a whole
lot about most international designs
look at but I do know I believe that
most Russian and Chinese design follow
that same thing because they're very
similar there is an interesting design
of their comes they're very similar
between Russia and Canada that they
actually use shorter bundles that are
round and shape because they use a heavy
water style reactor
but there they're just round with little
short but they can do online refueling
which is a little different than our
plans just shut our plants down to
refuel them got it and so how does the
land power plant differ from on a
submarine or an aircraft right when it's
what I'll call it mobile is it the same
design just on the smaller scale and in
a ship or submarine or is there some
difference in the design there there are
there are some differences but overall
they operate very much the same and the
differences are a relatively cosmetic
for this conversation but yeah they
basically do operate it's just a smaller
version it boils the water makes the
steam and then it either it spins the
turbine to make the make electricity or
it spins the turbines to drive the shaft
it puts moves to the best of holder
honor got it into throughout all of
these different designs these rods that
have the uranium pellets the one of the
questions that when I asked on Twitter
like hey what questions do we have a lot
of people are asking about our
dependence on uranium right obviously
uranium is a key component of this one
question is just is uranium the only
fuel source that can go into that and
then to kind of how do you think about
dependence on uranium our ability to
find more and if that's a risk or not so
based on a couple of scientific favors
that I've seen we have about a thousand
years of uranium-235 which is the fuel
that all US reactors use and we are very
inefficient with our fuel use of that we
literally only use about half of it or
so it may be a little more in half and
uranium-235 only makes up 0.7 percent of
all natural uranium so we're talking we
have a thousand years left of that type
of uranium and this is the thousand
years left but we have to continue to
dig it up or we've already kept like
capture and it's being stored so we have
to dig it out there we have to mine all
this and then now if we were to switch
to a fast reactor we could try it's
called transmute the uranium 238
that's the remaining 99.3% into
plutonium which could then do which then
if it receives the neutron will split
and one of the things that's fascinating
about that is that we were talking about
those control rods trying to get that
magic one want a fast reactor where
you're creating your own fields called
breeding you actually take one of those
your first new trying to keep the
reaction going your second Neutron
actually is going to create your your
new fuel and then you have to deal with
whatever's left a little little little
extra got it and so would it be fair to
say that the uranium-235 that that less
than 1% is that harder to find than the
uranium 238 and that's why there's such
a disparity in that and the percentages
or that's just how it like if you go
pick up a chunk of uranium you find if I
went out to a uranium mine and picked it
up it's just gonna be comprised of 99.3%
uranium 238 0.7% uranium-235 got it's
just it's all that's just how it is with
the exception there is one location
where it's different okay and that's the
natural reactor that ran two billion
years ago on a hundred thousand year
cycle is called Hoklo out in africa wait
what is this yeah they've little there's
a natural reactor that brand for like
million years and somewhere in Africa I
don't member specifically it's called
Oklo there's a Gen four company that
takes that as their name but it has
lower levels of B rhenium 235 because it
consumed it co-op to operate had
literally you know two billion years ago
we have this natural reactor that
operated before human beings existed
yeah and so as we think through this
there's it sounds like uranium
dependency we've got to continue to mine
uranium I don't think that there's a lot
of people who are necessarily concerned
about uranium existing it's more so we
just got to go get it right so there's
there's a cost of that etc this other
idea around this fast reactor is the
ability to take their uranium 238 and
change it into plutonium I think you
said and then use that as the the fuel
source is there controversy around
moving to fast reactors this is just an
expense like what's the why would we not
do that well one is the the regulations
under the Carter Administration they
they two things they did which kind of
prevents us from from going to fast
reactors and reducing our way stockpile
we can't reprocess waste and we're not
actually allowed to use plutonium
reactor
okay there's a concern because when you
hear plutonium people think weapons the
plutonium that the US has for weapons
was generated in special reactors
designed to make weapons-grade plutonium
the plutonium that exists in and we
generate plutonium in our and our
current reactors that's actually the
waste that everyone's concerned about
the last hundred thousand years but it
actually is not comprised of there it's
not pure enough to be used for weapons
so there's non weapons-grade yes yeah
it's it's it's pretty much garbage if
you want to make weapons with it it
would be a very expensive process that
is actually very harmful and could be
deadly and you know be easier to cost
issues yeah it'd be easier to do a
create a reactor to make if you want to
make plutonium for weapons okay so
before we go deeper down the the nuclear
kind of rabbit hole one of the things
that fascinates me right so I came into
this I knew absolutely nothing about it
and I really started to research and
look into it is when I think of
renewable or clean energy I think of
hydro I think of wind I think of solar
right there's plenty of others that
people put in that category whether they
should be or not but one of the biggest
issues that I did not understand before
I started looking at nuclear is there's
a a space and an environmental impact to
implementing a lot of that stuff right
and so obviously with solar you need
space to install the solar panels so
that the Sun can hit them and capture
that energy with wind you need to clear
out space so you can put the turbines
right so they can spin and obviously
capture the energy nuclear and before we
were talking has a much smaller
footprint maybe kind of just talk
through what that footprint difference
is and then we can get into some of the
things that nuclear may solve that those
others suffer even once they're
installed yeah so the the energy density
it's a smart intelligent way to say it
okay yeah that's that's what the you
know the if you go to the office of
nuclear energy that's the term you know
it's it's good to be a little dense
that's that's their their comment but
you know the fact is is that you know if
you take a one you know gigawatt
you know powerplant there's a nuclear
power plant you want to build a wind or
solar farm that's of equivalent
nameplate capacity
it requires somewhere between 750 and a
thousand times land space okay so if I
have a one gigawatt nuclear facility and
I want one gigawatt of wind or solar
I need 750 to a thousand X the amount of
space in order to generate that much
power
yeah and it's about 13 acres to do that
with nuclear so now you could do the
more you can do the math but what a lot
of people don't talk about specifically
the the wind and solar folks is what's
called capacity factor nuclear operates
at 92 percent capacity factor and we can
shut them down when we want to when in
solar operated but wind about 25 to 40
percent solar somewhere between 10 and
20 percent so now if you want that same
output capacity to match nuclear right
you're looking for wind and solar that's
750 to 1,000 now you're looking at you
know what is that 5 times you have 5 to
10 times that and then 4 and just so I
understand that the capacity factor
means that if the nuclear reactors on 92
percent of the time and they can do a
gigawatt of power then you can start to
actually calculate here's how much power
it's gonna generate over a year over two
years five years ten years etc but on
the solar or the wind it can't generate
power a hundred percent of the time
right and that's why those numbers
you're throwing out 10 to 20 percent for
I think you said solar and then 20 to 40
percent for wind and so you actually
have to have even more than just a
gigawatt of capacity because the
capacity usage is lower yeah absolutely
and if you look at you know solar is not
producing energy at night right I mean
and winds not producing if the winds not
blowing and if the winds blowing too
hard
Oh interesting yeah so when because you
don't want the turbine blades turning
too fast and so they literally shut them
down when it's too
when the wind is too fast because it'll
actually cause them to rip apart there's
some great videos on YouTube for that
you know cals of fleeing because of
these giant wind turbines and when you
look at it there's a great and I'll have
to shoot it to you but there's a great
infographic at a company called Thor
Khan they shows a I think a 12 megawatt
wind turbine and the blades are longer
than their 500 mega
power unit really the blades are maybe
stack the three blades together it's
bigger than their whole 500 megawatt
unit and it's like a 12 megawatt and
when you take the capacity factor you
know you're looking at it I'm going back
to the capacity factor right you know
nuclear when we operate it we typically
we ramp it up put it 200% keep it there
it's our base load energy in the US and
then wind and solar as you know the wind
starts blowing the power comes up when
it stops it comes down so it's berries
and then you have you know solar where
the sun is shining it's a cloudy day
you're not producing as much energy if
you get water spots on it you started
praising the surface you know the they
degrade over time too and one of the
things about nuclear a lot of people
don't know is it actually over time we
have been generating more power with it
to the point where with 97 reactors in
2018 we generated more energy for with
nuclear than we haven't in the history
of the United States then that even goes
back to when we had 120 reactors so we
used to have 120 reactors we're down
down we're now down to 97 but those 97
are producing more power than we did
when we had 120 which means that on a
per powerplant basis we're actually
having more efficient and more output
per power plant absolutely yeah you know
what was the reason for to go from 120
down to 97 well you know it's it's
interesting you know there there are
many reasons why you know competitive
elect electricity prices driving driving
the the plants out it's a lot of the a
lot of the plants to get shut down were
the smaller single unit facilities so if
you look in the u.s. most most of the
facilities that stay running are over
800 megawatts and per reactor or you
have multiple reactors and because it
comes down to a you know people thing
now if you look at a natural gas plant
80 percent of your cost is equipment 20
percent is people if you look at a
nuclear power plant 80 percent of your
cost is people 20 percent is equipment
because you have so many people
operating these things you know and you
look at a
sir there's a well use duke energy's
they have their smallest facilities in
811 megawatt power plant that has 780
employees it's a kind of employees yeah
their largest power plant produces 2069
megawatts and has a thousand 50
employees
all right so for 300 extra employees are
getting almost three times the power
output and so that's a baseline number
of employees per power plant is just
very high yes so and yes you have to
have a minimum number and then you know
you can add more units but you're not
like I don't need to have you know you
know I need to have Raptor engineers
that know how the reactors work but I
don't need to add you know if I have to
say for one facility unless so they to
add to for the next for the next reactor
I don't need to add one because I
designed my units to be the same so and
then if I have a third I might even you
know if I have a three you know I might
even need a third person mm-hmm right I
can just draw a fourth person I'm just
fine with three or with operators things
like that you know you typically have a
shift manager a unit supervisor and to
license for an operator's per unit well
if I have a 3 unit facility was one
control room I have one shift manager 3
unit supervisors right now I've reduced
the number of people just by 2 right
there for sure and so when I hear that
you know we had a hundred twenty we're
down to 97 now 97 there's 50 states I
would have thought oh it's probably like
2 per state right just easy math and
probably a stupid assumption but that
would have been my assumption when I was
looking at it it's actually only about
30 states have reactors what is the
logic behind those 30 states versus the
other 20 not having it is it regulations
is it something to do with the
environment but what's the thought
process so I can speak specifically
about some states so the state of Oregon
had you stub a plank had one single unit
reactor called Trojan that was shut down
the 1990s I could speak about it because
I grew up in Oregon ok
and when it was shut - well when it was
operating the Oregon legislation passed
a requirement that for Oregon to build
any new nuclear required a national
repository so you've heard of Yucca
Mountain right so an ass repository for
spent nuclear fuel okay and this is
a place to take the nuclear waste and
put it somewhere away from people yes
yeah and so Yucca Mountain you know we
were building it and then we shut it
down I think 2009 timeframe shut down
the process and so there's several
states that's a requirement um several
States nuclear didn't make sense for
like Wyoming very sparse you know what
you're talking these large plants now
you got large transmission lines when a
lot of times is better to do small
alright so you know if you're looking
you know say a small gas turbine or when
we get into the new nuclear we could
talk about you know there's these new
nuclear the way they can you know
instead of a 800 megawatt module they
have 60 megawatt mantra so they can come
in single unit three pack six pack or
twelve pack so zere yeah exactly yeah
that's the new scales design they're all
about the beer for sure and so okay so
there's certain states that have nuclear
there's certain states that don't and
you already kind of hit on a little bit
right is I think one of the biggest
critiques against it whether it's
reasonable or not or accurate or not is
people fear nuclear because they only
know one of three things either they
know nothing about it and it sounds
scary right you know I've heard of
nuclear bombs before like I don't want
that near me to is they've heard of
Three Mile Island Fukushima Chernobyl
right these places where there's been
issues or three is they actually are
somewhat sophisticated and their belief
is hey we're great at having reliable
power generation but we don't know what
to do with the waste and we don't have a
great solution for the waste so maybe
let's go through all three of those
things but before I do that it just eyes
are kind of like to keep people
understanding this isn't a what are we
gonna do in the future
right nuclear energy is 20% of all
electricity generating the United States
right it makes up more than 55% of all
clean energy in the United States and so
it's not a thing of like what are we
gonna do the future like it's already
here weren't we doing this and we've
been doing it for a long time you know
you told me before I was show recording
20% of the electricity United States
since 1990 right yes so it's been going
on for a long time that we've been doing
this people just haven't talked
or just didn't spend the time to really
learn about it I think yeah I mean and
that's true and I think at peak it was
40% of our energy production in the in
the 70 in the late 70s early 80s right
around the time of the Three Mile Island
accident I know you did a great job
summarizing I describe the issues and
three words and that's waste weapons and
meltdowns okay least weapons or meltdown
yeah all right go so and so
all right the waste right there's two
responses to that one is is that the
wastes are stored in first when it's
pulled from the reactors putting two
spent fuel pool to cool down over time
against what is a spent fuel it's
basically it looks like a big giant
swimming pool that has old used fuel
rods in it and it just sits in there to
cool down because you can't you don't
want them to get too hot so these are
the fuel rods that have the uranium in
them that were in their reactor itself
right we now take them and really
submerge them in liquid that literally
looks like a swimming pool in terms of
the size of the things that's but it's
liquid that it's being submerged to cool
it off
yeah that's an Olympic it's an Olympic
swimming pool and there's 20 feet of
water over the fuel oh wow yeah those
are not small yeah okay it's a really
the reason for putting it into the spent
fuel pool is to cool off the rod yes
yeah so there's something called
residual heat so when the atoms split
you have these they're called fission
products and those fission products take
time to decay this is the term people
talk about the long term of waste most
those fission products will be gone in
300 years and we can talk about that as
part of the waste solution as well but
those fission products they they
generate heat when they are losing their
radioactivity okay so that's the concern
it's a toxicity of is the radioactivity
that everyone talks about so how long in
the spent fuel pool if I have a rod I
put it in there how long do I leave it
in there on average typically about a
decade oh wow is it okay I was thinking
like when you you know burn your finger
and you run under cold water for two
minutes in the sink this is not that
this is you're leaving it in there for
10 plus years yeah to cool off so yeah
so typically they're in about a decade
and then they and then they move them
into a what's called a spent fuel cask
okay what is that it's it's they look
like giant pills for the most part okay
there there they have a stainless steel
internal lighter they have concrete
around that and then stainless steel
they're welded and then they're filled
with helium okay so one it sounds almost
like humans have caskets these have
these casts yeah right yes that's a
great analogy okay and so you put the
spent fuel rods into this cast and you
close it up why is the helium going to
it um the healing goes in there so that
remember that there's still some heat
left okay and if it was in a vacuum it
wouldn't be good it would it would it
would there would be thermal you know
insulation and it would start to
potentially melt
I'm helium is a great conductor of heat
as a gas and so they pressurize a helium
so that it'll it'll conduct that heat to
the outside and cool it but you've
allowed him to cool sufficiently to
where just the you know the air out in
the middle of buta southern Florida out
in Miami you know will is sufficient to
keep them from having any problems got
it so I take the rods I put them in this
immersion pool if you are yeah never I
take him out a decade later I put into
this cast it's got all the fancy
interlining outer lining concrete etc I
seal it with the helium what do I do
with that cast once I've got the rods in
there so they all sit at the sites Oh in
Genting yeah this mount is this
controversial thing that from the the
critics of nuclear do they not like that
I mean that's this is the waste that
everyone is concerned about okay I got
it and I mean as far as the quantity of
this if you took all the casks and you
brought them into if you put them on a
football field it only be 50 feet deep
so I could cover 100 yards 50 feet deep
yeah it would be all of her all the
spent fuel from commercial operations in
the United States and that's been how
long 60 years 60 years okay so as you're
putting those on site is it we don't
have a better place to go put them or we
actually think the best place to put
them is on site well we talked about
Yucca Mountain earlier they were
supposed to all be shipped to Yucca
Mountain but since Yucca Mountain the
whole country was gonna go to this one
location yeah
yes and and the utilities actually
funded Yucca Mountain Oh interesting
yeah so those I mean there was some
taxpayer dollars to it but it was
primarily funded by the different energy
companies that had nuclear reactors do
you know why that place specifically was
chosen
um it's or just far away from it was I
mean it was it was in the Nevada desert
in a mountain I feel like the especially
Americans we just feel like at the
Desert Inn side of a mountain like
output area 51 put with the cast etc
well and we actually have a long-term
repository the government they built one
call that's called the Waste Isolation
Pilot Plant pilot program it's called
the blip facilities in Carlsbad New
Mexico okay and that's where the u.s.
sends its waste from weapons production
okay and now that's that we were not
generating new material for weapons but
there's a lot of legacy waste you're in
the news talking about that that
sarcophagus thing out in Marshall
Islands you've got Hanford you've got
the nasty reciting about others the US
has a lot of black well we'll get to the
weapons in a theater I got a lot of
questions out the weapons so right now I
take the cast that have the rods sealed
with helium I'll leave them on-site
that's for a land-based nuclear power
plant what happens on the submarines in
the aircraft the fuel is removed and it
is shipped out to Idaho got it and I'm
assuming there's just one repository
where all US military whatever goes in
yeah got it and so why is it once it's
inside of that cast its on-site so is it
safe
is it a thing where people are worried
about the the seal may break what like
what is the concern I guess on the waste
side and what happens if let's say a
worker at the facility goes and picks up
one and doesn't have protective clothing
on but like walk me through kind of how
radioactive are they and then what's the
concern from from the critics so you can
walk up and hug him and receive I'm not
gonna do that yeah I mean why hi yeah
but there's little you have to get
little denote dose you'd probably get
more radiation dose heating a banana
then you would from hugging one of those
casks really and it's because not so
much that the fuel of spent fuel rods
don't have radiation it's that they're
locked into the actual cast itself and
so the outside of the cast is not seeing
anything radiation yeah so the the
stainless steel and the concrete are
acting as shielding got it okay so yeah
it's it's providing shielding for that
now if that fuel was unshielded and you
drove a truck up to or drove a car it
added at 55 miles an hour or you would
not survive okay so if it was just
sitting on the side of the road yeah
there was nothing protecting it and you
just drove right by it yeah that's
that's and that's why we have the 20
feet of water over them and you know the
people that work on this stuff they are
very you know wary or worried they're
very sensitive
yeah sensitive to what they're doing got
it
and so you explained why the helium is
locked in in the cast
what's up with the water why is the
water is that a better protection than
the than the inner lining outer lining
in the concrete it's talked about in the
in the spent fuel in the pool um well
it's it's readily available the other
thing is is that when they're when
commercial reactors are they're removing
the fuel during their outages they have
to this every 18 months 18 to 24 months
they have to literally take the whole
reactor out they take about it they slot
it's about a third swap they take about
a they bring a third new fuel in a third
of the fuel is completely consumed and
then they basically have to reassemble
the reactor because the the way the rods
are to make sure you have the right the
right you know heat loading in there so
to do that they literally fill the
reactor it's called the vessel cavity up
with water they picked the fuel rods up
they move it through water into the fuel
building oh wow yeah so it's all done
there's always always in water yep yeah
it's fascinating to me how the entire
process right is so compartmentalized
and and and at the end of the day I
think one of the things I took away the
most from the research and conversations
I have with users this is
right and if we get the science right
then you get into how are the systems
designed what are the protocols that the
humans have to interact with those
systems and we have to make sure that
were right on the sides right yeah we do
that then we can create safe systems
okay so I think you've done a good job
describing like how we deal with the
waste right now we'll come back to that
in a second but there's been these three
big events where there's been the issues
right so the waste is one but these
accidents is another I forget that the
three were gee yeah it was waste weapons
and meltdowns so this falls under here
meltdown meltdown okay so let's go maybe
through the three Three Mile Island
Fukushima and Chernobyl and maybe just
describe what happened and each one of
them all right well I'm first off I'm
gonna say that there have been eight
meltdowns planet-wide of commercial
reactors total okay no yeah so ever and
three of those are Fukushima and two of
them were in France okay so on same site
right so so that covers five of the
eight and then there was three mile
island and Chernobyl and I believe
Russia had one mother now we talked
about through Milan because that's the
only true commercial meltdown there were
some test reactors and melted down but
these were who we were doing silly
things at that point we didn't know what
we're doing because that was like in the
60s 79 yes every night yeah so 79
cheating I have notes you have your
brain I um so Three Mile Island and you
know it's it's there's was it was an
operator error the reactor was brand new
and what I mean brand new it had gone
online for the first time two months
prior to the accident
oh well so you know you're looking at
reactors there did license for 40 years
or extend most of them to 60 and now we
even have something extended 80 years
and this thing lasted two months before
we destroyed it but they had that guy
got fired yeah or he died no one died
okay yeah no one died and the public
only received about one and one dental
x-rays worth of radiation is that a lot
no no now you get four typically when
you go to the dentist I said okay yeah
that's not a lot ready oh well I was
asking now what's on top I had somebody
recently a dentist actually recently
told me that Grand Central has a lot of
radiation because of the
materials that it's used in the
construction I think sign it yeah he
said it's like a big radiation box and
now I'm like scared to walk through
Grand Central well there's actually a
video I tweeted out there of a nuclear
engineer that has uranium oxide which is
the fuel that we use like literally he
had nuclear fuel in his hand and it's
been a powder form and he literally
licks it and swallows no he does not he
does what how can you do that it's it's
radioactive it's not that radioactive oh
man you're getting me the weird world
okay all right so let's correct it
through my so like operator error
yeah radiation that goes out but it's
not that high yeah so what they had was
they had they had a relief valve who
they had a had a relief out had a slight
leak by and so there's a temperature
indication down that's beyond that
relief us relief valve basically to keep
the pret make sure that you don't get
too much pressure and then you cause a
trinova event which is you know over
pressurize you're planted steam
explosion with bed so this relief valve
was leaking and so the the piping
downstream was getting hot and so they
had this indication that they were
living with and so when they had their
problem the relief valve lifted as it
should should and then it didn't receipt
so it didn't shut and so they started
basically dumping their water out of the
reactor and they actually lowered the
pressure to the point where there's a
piece of equipment called the
pressurizer which keeps this pressurized
water reactor so the pressurizer keeps
us pressurized and it uses electric
heaters to keep on a much higher
pressure and basically they way they
call it transferred the bubble so they
basically moved the steam void in there
now steam does not conduct heat very
well and so they basically cause that
the fuel assemblies the fuel rods they
got too hot and they melt it's kind of
like you ever seen in Germany with the
boots when they chug beer and they have
the bubble and as a boot right yeah yeah
yeah pretty similar okay so that's Three
Mile Island I think that that's probably
the lesser-known of the three right and
that mainly just because Fukushima and
Chernobyl have been more recent and
also Chernobyl now has a whole
documentary series or whatever it was
that was create on television what
happened at Chernobyl
alright so Chernobyl which happened in
86 is that they were running a test that
it was basically forced on that now the
Soviet Union to the former Soviet Union
that sign up no Chernobyl's actually
physically locate in Ukraine okay so but
the former Soviet Union they wanted to
run this test to prove and this is the
part that blows my mind is it was to
prove that in the event that they were
to lose off-site power as it's known
that as the the turbine was spinning
down it could keep the reactor cool so
they were basically running this test to
ensure that the reactor could not
meltdown and it went way wrong so base
basically saying we're going to try to
melt it down and show you that this
system will prevent it from building
yeah essentially yes yeah so what
happened is well actually they would be
geniuses if it works if it doesn't work
then they're idiots right yeah well so
they had some design flaws they were
operating at too low of powers they had
to withdraw these these things called
control rods they had such a goes 48
that had to be completely inserted at
all times and they withdrew them all so
they're violating their safety
procedures they're doing a test that the
reactor engineers were completely
against because I you told me earlier
that there was four separate teams or
kind of divisions inside of Chernobyl
three the first three that they went to
said no way I'm not running that test
they knew that it was a bad thing to do
and somehow the fourth order they were
forced or agreed or whatever they end up
running the test yeah absolutely yeah
yeah and they're running the test on my
understanding is a different design than
US based reactors yes yeah so US based
us reactors don't have that same flaw
that exists now none of our reactors had
that so and as they were running the
test they had what's called a power
screws and power started coming up but
they were at these such low powers that
the equipment couldn't respond properly
and when they finally went to take some
action basically they had overheated the
reactor to the point where it oh I don't
want a steam explosion
right so you know it's a be take you
know the best I describe is you just
take a jar and you put some water in it
and you seal it up and you put it on a
stove it's eventually gonna you know
explode right because you did a little
too much steam in there don't try that
at home yeah it's put glass all over the
place well in this case yeah they
literally you know they shot fuel all
over the place right going back to that
whole you know drive a truck up to it
and got it and so earlier you said Three
Mile Island was one whatever level of
radiation the dentist is for Africa yeah
yeah yeah so yeah so one one dental
x-ray which is about three millirem and
then as Apple one dental x-ray I got it
how much Chernobyl I'm assuming Weibull
um well the Chernobyl killed 31 people
okay and those were all plant-based
employees I I don't know the specifics
on each person I think some were
firefighters and but people who they
weren't civilians that live next door
correct got it and so that 31 people
that are killed one of the things I
guess is how much of that is explosion
related right like there's this big
explosion and they died in the explosion
versus natural radiation itself there
were I know that there were there were
several people that were killed but the
majority were from the radiation
exposure from the radiation okay so so
basically this is a perfect example of
hey if things go really really wrong and
this stuff is not done correctly if
there is super an error if the systems
are have design flaws people can die
because there's radiation correct now
one of the things that's fascinating is
is that every reactor in the United
States has what's called a containment
okay right that's a it's a big it's a
steel line go back to the stainless
steel lined with concrete steel
reinforced now the rebar is literally
you know about three inches in diameter
so this is not you know there's not the
rebar you go by Home Depot this is you
know so what you're basically saying is
just like that spent fuel rods put
inside of the cast basically the entire
facility is put inside of a cast
essentially essentially there's an inner
lining US concrete and outer lining
there's only an inner liner there's
about yeah that's to contain anything
that happens with inside yeah so if if
if
us designs can't undergo at renoble
explosion but if they did it would be
contained inside the containment now
that being said the u.s. actually had
its its own Chernobyl event that no one
talks about oh really yes there was an
army reactor so I know you were army
there's an army reactor this is where
the Navy guy gives me a hard time don't
worry it was a sailor involved - it was
it was called sl1 there was a stationary
light water reactor one and so they were
running some kind of evolution now this
is so early on a nuclear that those rods
I was talking about like we use a switch
that drives some motors and and it moves
the rods up and down they moved them
manually probably not healthy well it's
really not healthy one you know he was
told to withdraw it three inches and
whether he just decided he didn't want
to have his life anymore or misheard and
tried to withdraw thirteen inches but he
you know we talked about they control
that reaction but you haven't you're
you're relying on humans to do this
mm-hmm right harped our plants don't
rely on humans to do that anymore and
that's one of those those reasons God
and this was a land-based power plant or
this was a like a submarine aircraft it
was a a land-based military reactor got
it okay and so that happened
1961 okay so this is way before even
through my island yeah it sure looks
that sure got it yeah even when I was
researching I didn't see that at all
yeah there because the military based
one or something yeah it's it's one of
the fascinating ones that most people
don't know about and yeah so that's and
it contained itself all three of the
operators were killed it's the worst by
deaths nuclear acts in the United States
so but because of but because as the
containment yeah it was everything was
contained inside of it that sites been
cleaned up now I mean you know it's it's
unfortunate that three people lost their
lives okay so speaking of containment
and the lack of containment
I think Fukushima is at least in my
lifetime the only thing that we've known
in terms of like nuclear is bad right
type Meem
what happened there and then literally
the only thing that I can remember when
that occurred was you know people
walking around in the white suits and
with the gloves and the goggles and
everything right and just like it's like
everything's gonna die there right and
so I don't know what's fact and fiction
and kind of how that occurred and was
her containment was there not it was
talked through that so so the Fukushima
reactors we actually have this exact
same design in the US and certain
locations okay so it's they are a
boiling water reactor which is different
than the Three Mile Island Chernobyl so
instead of having it's that we don't
need go in that technical detail but so
the suit the earthquake happened and
then the reactor they shut down the
reactors because of the earthquake and
they had a tidal wave come in and it
washed out their burn shoe system so
when the reactors shut down so just real
quick this is really important right is
this was not human error to start with
this was not system design flaw there
was a massive earthquake that then
created a tsunami that tsunami brought
water for those that no tsunami brings
water right brought water onto the plant
and that's where somebody's issue
started yeah absolutely so normally
because we were talking about those
those those rods that are in the spent
fuel pool when we talk about you know
that we got to worry about those fission
products they get hot for a long period
time we keep them in there for a decade
right so when a reactor shuts down they
have systems in place to start cooling
keeping that reactor cool to cool it
down to keep that that fuel from you
know melting down that's that's the
whole purpose of these emergency systems
well the tsunami was so large at
Fukushima that it actually exceeded what
the Japanese nuclear regulatory
requirements were it was higher than
that so they it exceeded that washed out
all their safety systems so they
couldn't keep the reactor cool and so
that's what happened now the explosions
that occurred which is actually funny
which is funny it's interesting is that
three reactors melted down and there
they operated there were total six
reactors are three or more D fuel but
there are in pairs and one of the
reactors had exploded actually had no
fuel a
how does that happen so what happens is
that when you get the the fuel rods
themselves or their a tube that outer
tube is made with zirconium okay and
when inner cone iam is in contact with
water at high temperatures above 2000
degrees it rapidly oxidizes and creates
hydrogen gas I'm not a scientist but I
know that that leads to bad things
sometimes and so the hydrogen gas was
filling up there yeah it wasn't there
containments it it felt there
containments but it would filled up
their reactor buildings the auxilary
buildings and then it got to an
explosive level and exploded the
explosions were unnecessary if the
Japanese government had allowed the
operators to vent as they were
requesting the reactor buildings would
not have met would not have exploded and
the accident would not be as bad okay so
the tsunami hits they wash out these
emergency systems right which basically
the regulator's had regulations in place
but they just never imagined a tsunami
this big exactly when those emergency
systems get washed out how does the
explosion interact with that washing out
of the emergency system so like what is
it the explosion then like breaks
containment and then that's what happens
well how does the explosion so the so
the explosion actually so you have the
the the the containment is actually it's
a it shaped like a bullet okay and it's
inside their reactor building it's on a
boiling water reactor that's how it is
and you have your and so the hydrogen
gas is being vented in there so the the
cooling system is all down below all
that stuff and so the hydrogen gas is
hydrogen is lighter than air so it goes
up and so it's rising into the the
reactor building itself and that's when
it exploded and they wanted to vent it
out they want to continue to rise out
yes and they weren't allowed to and and
the reason why they weren't allowed to
is because of this magical word called
tritium tritium what is that it's just a
heavy it's an extra heavy form of water
tritium is an extra it's to have a form
of hydrogen with hydrogen okay right and
you know tritium is generated naturally
in the atmosphere so you've got I've got
a glass of water right here I'm going to
consume some tritium in front
and why are people scared at tritium
tritium sounds like one of those words
that if people don't know what it is it
sounds scary but what is the fear there
well the fear well one it's radioactive
right and everything radioactive is just
sounds scary because people don't
necessarily understand what radioactive
means the other thing is is that when
you talk about a thermal nuclear weapon
so you've got you know the hiroshima
nagasaki which were just atomic weapons
right well the thermal nuclear weapon
requires fusion and tritium is the key
for fusion so basically you have more
feels like bomb material got it okay and
basically they didn't want to allow the
tritium yet right air quotes to go up
into the air yep right okay and
potentially affect the population now so
we have the fukushima of that and
fukushima killed zero people by the way
okay so nobody down nobody died when
that happens what is the radiation
levels outside of that containment and
then kind of why and maybe this is just
the salacious media but why do we see on
television people walking around the
white suits and kind of so the purpose
of the white suits is if you have any
kind of radioactive dust okay that it
stays on the white suit so you take
those off they're called protective
clothing and the idea is it I don't want
to take that home okay so basically it's
while I'm in a potentially radioactive
area I may the suit isn't necessary
gonna protect me from the radiation what
it's gonna do is it's gonna prevent me
from transporting any radioactive
material back to some other location
yeah so one when a nuclear reactor
undergoes an outage you you wear those
we I mean what do you everyone put yeah
you ever put some on there when you're
when you're working in the containment
building okay got it you know and then
in terms of the actual damage that was
created by Fukushima right to me it's a
there was this huge issue was there
actually negative impact on the
environment on people etc or was it all
pretty self contained and people just
talk about it because there was an
explosion excetera
yeah so there because the fact there
were three explosions and there were
three reactors that were melted down and
destroyed
there so you have the equipment aspect
of it there were scarce people in jobs
yes and and then the the fear of the
radiation that the Japanese government
amplified by force evacuations actually
caused I believe several hundred people
that were say elderly to you know when
they went to transport them or not they
did it in a rushed manner and it played
they lost their lives because of fear
really yeah so so there were people who
lost their lives but not because of
radiation lost their lives due to
elderly I don't have medical care etc
yeah medical care well you need intense
care and then we're gonna transport you
in a rushed manner when you didn't need
to rush it got it I mean the radiation
levels that that are on the site are
such that you could stand there for
years and not have issues mm-hmm on the
site and so this is probably good time
to talk about again I'm coming at this
so uneducated right that I'm looking at
this as how to understand nuclear power
generation and what it can do for the
United States and other countries but
also understanding you know the other
side of this where people are fearful
etc what does radiation do to the human
body at certain level strikes I'm
assuming that it kind of wretches
wretches if I go the dentist I get
radiation right I joke all the time I
say when you get on an airplane get
radiation when you go through the thing
that spins at security get radiation so
I'm still alive you're still alive right
yeah I mean you're you get somewhere
between depending on what source they
talk about somewhere between 150 and 500
milligram a year from natural sources
okay 150 to 500 milligram yes okay to
give you an idea to give you you know a
baseline in 20 years enable service I
received 247 milligram from nuclear
reactors okay
so 100 to 500 is kind of average just
naturally naturally yeah 240 in dumb
question but how do you measure that how
do right can I walk around with
something that tells me how much
radiation um yeah I mean well so and
it's funny I'll talk about that is that
we call it they're called TLDs
thermoluminescence emitters it's the
words and ones we had to look like
little fat pen
okay and they measured everything so
when you wore them you know you got
natural and unnatural radiation you got
all of it and the new ones we have there
they're little squares and they
discriminate so the first half of my
naval career we use the the otherwise
the Pens and so I would be in port on a
shutdown reactor and my monthly exposure
was about nine millirem underway and I
was to watch standard that sat that was
closest to the reactor as it was
operating I got four Wow and I wasn't
getting any from that reactor when it
was shut down it was all from the Sun
and yeah yeah okay ensue
that's like let's call that low-level no
concern level radiation exposure what
are the levels in which people should be
concerned and like what happens to the
human body okay because in my mind it's
like you get exposed to radiation you
melt and like you're dead yeah so um
it's all occurs at the cellular level
and the way it was taught to me is they
we call it good daughter dead daughter
bad daughter no daughter okay explain
that so what happens is that the the
radiation strikes the DNA of the nucleus
and good daughter the the cell repairs
itself divides normally okay all right
then there's bad daughter and this is
the one that scares most people because
it's hard to understand is that it it
damages the new the the DNA in the in
the nucleus of the cell it splits and
it's got a problem this is the cancer
that everyone is concerned about got it
so there's some sort of mutation to the
cells yes then there's the dead daughter
which is the DNA is damaged cell splits
the cells both die the new cells both
died the daughter cells do and that's
good or bad
it's neither neither I'm well a night
what he in radiation sickness if you get
large quantities of radiation that's a
problem yeah and then you have no
daughter which is that it just basically
radiation just kills the cell god so
those last two are radiation sickness
with the and then you have the cancer
for the the bad daughter the way it was
trained to me was that if you took a
of 10,000 people about 1,000 of them are
going to die of cancer okay all right
at what level I'm just normal natural
like just living a normal okay got it
if you took those same 10,000 people and
you exposed them to one Ram or 1000
milligram of radiation over their
lifetime potentially one thousand and
one would now die of cancer
okay so there's a very small very small
yeah so so 1,000 millirem yes right okay
and when you think about through my
island people got three outside of plant
workers right now when you're talking
cancer it's - there's so many variables
right and people will say well there was
increased cancer rates here it's like
well what chemicals were they exposed to
you firefighters cancer is the number
one killer of firefighters because
they're inhaling smoke and all the
chemicals associated with it
these old plants used asbestos is the
asbestos that they that they breathe in
that's causing the cancer so we don't
know you know and if you look at a coal
plant they use asbestos and you know old
plants use asbestos so it's not that you
know the radiation is causing the cancer
there's lots of variables we don't know
and and this is timely because for those
that listen to podcasts often plane and
Joe are here in the room and they're
gonna start laughing when I say this but
I've recently read a book called the
telomere effect and so it's a a
professor who did a bunch of academic
research all around these telomeres and
telomeres are essentially on your DNA at
the very ends think of them kind of like
on your shoelaces how you have that
plastic cap yep they can start at a
certain length and over the lifetime
they shorten as you they shorten you
look older you age right things get
worse than machine you die and so one of
the things that goes into that other
than you know how you eat exercise all
the things we all know radiation and so
what they've talked about is things like
flying well if you fly a whole lot like
your telomeres shorten right if you stop
flying so much after years of doing it
you can actually slow down the
shortening of your telomeres there's
nothing to do with their power plants
etc that's just natural human
kind of reactional relationship with
what the things that they're doing in
the environment etc and so of that talk
about the cancer one of the things is if
you continue to get exposed to that and
your telomeres shortening shortening
shorten there can be kind of the
continued growth of cells etc that's
where you get the cancers from and so
you know this isn't to me at least kind
of an uneducated perspective it's not
just a nuclear power plant related type
thing this is just human body science
and biology how we interact with the
things around us and an airline pilot
gets more radiation being an airline
pilot or Stewart as they get more
radiation flying a year than a nuclear
power plant operator gets operating a
reactor that's pretty crazy yeah yeah
alright let's let's talk about the big
topic which I know everyone's all
excited about which is the weapons right
so when people hear nuclear weapons it's
like if you're a pro conflict Pro
military let's go fight everybody in the
world people get excited because it's
best the aggressive you know most
powerful weapons type approach if you
are let's deescalate every situation and
we don't want war we don't want you know
issues et cetera nobody should have
nuclear weapons right or kind of like
that the opposite is the spectrum there
what is a nuclear weapon right and how
does that relate to nuclear power etc so
you can it requires the same fuels okay
assuming the rods from uranium 239
meaning the uranium-235 core the
plutonium 239 okay alright so that core
fuel is yes used for both power plants
and for the nuclear weapon but they are
very different okay so a nuclear reactor
does never never can never achieve two
geometry is that is the term they use
okay to have a nuclear explosion okay
explain as best you can kind of why that
is um you can't get the atoms close
enough because they're at an oxide there
in those they're there in those rods
right whereas in a nuclear weapon you
actually it starts in
I'm not an expert in nuclear weapons
yeah well yeah we'll leave that too and
this this really cracks me up
- Markby Schneider no way
I'm not joking b4 bombs efore energy I
love it so um literally that one of the
leading experts in nuclear weapons in
the US market be shy oh man that's
awesome
yeah so like and the the best way to
describe this is talk about the the atom
bombs dropped on Hiroshima Nagasaki okay
because Hiroshima was a uranium bomb
Nagasaki was a plutonium bomb okay all
right so the way that the hiroshima bomb
was was that it was it's it's a plug
type meaning that it's a cylinder like a
like a glass with thick walls okay and
they have a bullet of uranium and they
use an explosion from you know gunpowder
whatever drives it in there you have
enough you hit your critical geometry
and it causes that uncontrolled reaction
we talked about the neutrons earlier
where the one causes you know the atom
to split generates a couple extra those
split everything you know that it goes
through all this yeah hold and see if it
uncontrolled you know the mass amounts
of heat generated heat light energy so
that's how the base of that and in
plutonium weapon they're at a sphere and
there's lots of explosions around it and
you have to explode them all into the
center to get the right geometry and
they're simultaneously and caused that
explosion got it and so the I guess
where some of the concern is so to the
uneducated its hey the word nuclear is
in both and like that's scary right
because I saw on TV there's this big
explosion I don't want that to happen
down the street from my house or you
know somewhere near me to the educated
it's actually the fuel source can be the
same but the geometry is the the big
differentiator between the two of them
and you have to look at the
concentration of the fuel - right we
talked about the percentages so in a
nuclear reactor a u.s. reactor we
typically use about two to four percent
enriched uranium-235 so I meaning - four
percent of your fuel is is uranium-235
and a weapon it's greater than 90% Wow
for the difference yes and same thing
with plutonium right so our reactors do
generate plutonium we talked about those
excess neutrons so I'm gonna bore by
that uranium 238 but it's about one
percent you still need that high 90
percent pure plutonium 239 the plutonium
in our reactors is actually an 80/20
blend of plutonium 239 and plutonium-240
that 240 actually makes the reaction not
viable for making an effective new god
weapon and is their concern I've never
heard this but this is just me thinking
how others might might be concerned is
there a concern that countries that are
pursuing nuclear power could use some of
the learnings there and experience there
to then create nuclear weapons or those
two so separate things that they're not
really concerned so typically it's there
is a good overlap between them okay
right so now sonic a science scientific
aspect so now to make a new day a
uranium bomb which is everyone's big
concern with Iran right now
and by the way Iran I think is at six
percent enrichment so they've got
another 84 percent to go before we
should be concerned when we say
enrichment what does that mean that's
the the percentage of uranium-235 in the
uranium okay so they've they've gotten
to make to about six percent and they
have I think three hundred and twenty
kilograms of this stuff okay
there's 3.2 million kilograms of spent
nuclear fuel and Virginia alone much
less yeah and and we're at a hundred
percent enrichment what's that
as far as the u.s. enrichment know there
are that fuel is only enriched while the
spent fuel is actually down to about one
okay because we've consumed the yeah pre
consumption pre consumption it was two
to four percent got it okay right so so
that fuel is sorry so the so you're an
Iran has a long ways to go before we
should be concerned in fact actually
there's a new scales accompany the
duties and medium enriched we're gonna
get a special report allowance to go to
nineteen point seven five percent
enrichment so the reactors can last
longer they only did refuel every 12
years okay and so the concern
with a country doing nuclear energy
related activities and then kind of pull
back the curtain and oh now we have a
nuclear bomb is that more science
fiction consumer so that the the two
countries that are of concern are Iran
and North Korea okay
now Iran you know they have their
centrifuges right that's what makes the
the enrichment happen and the uranium is
the easiest method to make a weapon okay
and then North Korea however they
designed a special reactor at least I
believe this I don't know everything I
don't know all the details of it and
this is kinda we're delving far outside
what I'm normally you know attuned with
but I believe North Korea I was use that
word I believe North Korea has a reactor
they designed specifically to generate
plutonium now that plutonium you if you
keep her in has to remain in a reactor
for less than six months we the fuel in
a reactor stays in there for four and a
half years before you pull it out
normally right so that's the normal
method so if you we got countries I know
that United Arab Emirates is about
they're gonna put on their Baraka unit
one will be they'll be number 31 on the
countries of nuclear power and they're
gonna bring theirs online and it's a
South Korean reactor design and I I
don't think anyone should be concerned
about them you know
whereas you know it there's really you
know I'd like to break down the nuclear
power program and loose in the u.s. into
three groups okay you've got the
commercial which are your big scale
reactors they do produce a lot of the
nuclear waste but it's benign from a
weapons standpoint okay you have the
Navy reactors which run on very pure
fuels but they're military so they get
exceptions for that and then you have
this third group which is the Department
of Energy those are your test reactors
and so those are the ones where I mean
you're making medical isotopes with it
but you're putting fuel fuels in and out
of those things if you are to you know
you got to be concerned when nations or
building tests react
so if they're building commercial
reactors just let him build them all day
long they're not gonna make you can't
make weapons materials from those it's
test reactors you got to be concerned
about and why is the test reactors is it
because they are that they're more
closely aligned with what's needed to
make a weapon than with a commercial
correct yeah yeah so so in a commercial
reactor it's this big ordeal to
disassemble the reactor and pull the
fuel out where is it a test reactor they
might be like they might never operate
the thing hot enough to really boil
water right but they're generating tons
and tons of neutrons to irradiate fuels
or I mean it you know and they use that
stuff for for good you know you know
anybody old test reactors aren't bad but
there's risk yes but all test reactors
could become made to do bad things got
it okay I want to go back to to the
waste because I know that's um you know
when I think of like what is the biggest
critique it's around this waste
component and again I think you know
when I was reading online I'm uneducated
on the topic right and I'm trying to
learn and so again there's a spectrum of
like there's plenty of people who just
yell and scream like Chernobyl Fukushima
they don't they don't know right it's
like you know that's my favorite reply
yeah if you if you don't know it's scary
right cuz the radiation and almost got
some radioactive material all accustomed
but then there's the people who are
actually super sophisticated and I think
that the very educated sophisticated
critic would say okay we go through this
great process we've produced tons of
reliable power and electricity we do
we're getting more efficient at it right
it absolutely could be a great solution
their biggest concern is once that spent
fuel rod goes into the pool then goes
into this cast
we either one can't guarantee that the
cast is sealed forever and kind of a
life of the waste that we could talk
about but then also too is then we leave
this cast on site like we don't go put
it anywhere right we touched a little
bit on like where do we go put this
stuff and it sounds like yeah there's
been kind of initiatives to go put it in
a mountain in the middle of the desert
etc but in terms of the life of the
waste the number that I have always
heard is a hundred thousand years this
stuff stays radioactive for right and
I'm sure that there's some decay in the
radioactive
kind of levels that it has but a hundred
thousand years I think just scares
people cuz that's a really really long
time right
how accurate is that and are there
things that we can do to just shorten
the lifetime of the radioactive nature
of this waste and then to like how do we
ensure that that that helium sealed cast
actually stays sealed um well the first
off the casters are welded they're
welded yeah so yeah it's not like
they're welded shut okay and so would
you say it there's not really a concern
that once it's welded shut nothing's
gonna happen to it or is there still
some concern I would the concern is
extremely minimal okay and I say that
because I just don't want to be an
absolutist yep no I haven't I personally
have no concern but you know I want to
be you know is trying to be honest here
as well but is question yeah yeah okay
so let me kind of walk through each one
so no concern if the cast just is the
right self-antigen shut no problem if
there was an explosion
in a plant or the cast usually held in
an area where it could be affected by an
explosion and would that cause an issue
that would not know because I mean
they're typically they're they're
they're stored far enough away from the
plant and they're actually require less
security than the reactor the reactor
does itself because they're I mean these
cats they're not like you know a simple
thing they require special heavy cranes
to pick them up and move them so it's
not like you can go throw one of these
things in the bed of your pickup truck
which which is that's what the image is
is always these yellows assistants yeah
right the the the Simpsons the podcast I
listen to from the Department of Energy
they actually started off talking about
there was this Simpsons episode all
about you know radioactive material at a
nuclear power plant and you know all
this stuff goes wrong etc and later on
The Simpsons producer came out and
apologized and said look you know we're
basically making jokes we didn't
understand what we were making a joke
about and you know we apologize
okay so that'sthat's first the second is
in terms of the human error that can get
introduced in
with this waste so whether it's taking
the spent fuel rod and putting it into
the immersive pool or then getting it
into the cast like where are the failure
points or potential failure points there
and how big of a risk is that um
well-being is that the heat
there are failure points but the risk at
this point is extremely minimal you know
right now you know basically a third of
all the reactors in the US underwent an
outage this this fall okay now dudes
meaning how did you meaning if they shut
the reactor down they pulled all the
fuel out they left 1/3 of it in the
spent fuel pool and they stuck a third
new and then they put 2/3 of it back
together on there ok I move on you know
these fuel assemblies so there's there's
fail-safes there's lots of experience
and they're probably the worst location
with regards to this is there's a camera
the name of the plant and it's good it's
done down near san diego where the plant
is shut down and they are in that final
process of taking those spent those rods
that have been in there for a decade so
it's been shut down for that long and
they're putting them in their final
casks to then to put them store them on
site so that's that's probably your
biggest risk and there's it's all over
the place and you know you have the NRC
is is huge amounts of regulation huge
amounts of oversight fuel movement is
one of the most you have special extra
qualifications and I know this is not
people people in here is because you're
putting the human element in there but
there's the amount of times this is done
if there was a problem ashido because
the nuclear industry drives levels down
their problems down so low that you
don't bubble up the same kind of
problems right we're talking low order
magnitude issues guy Hong's a tag on the
wrong component the plant shuts down for
24 hours to do a safety stand-down to
realign everyone meanwhile you use the
comparison the oil and gas industry you
know down in North Carolina they have a
guy operate the wrong route blows up
three people
and you know that's an eye right so
there's a big difference the way the the
the we regulate and we operate the
nuclear industry I like to say that
after through my Island the commercial
industry decided to or made the decision
to put the NRC out of business which the
NRC is a nuclear expert so they're the
government oversight and they created an
organization called the Institute of
nuclear power operations okay so the
utilities fund this so this is self
regulation you know hear about this
often but the utility funds this
organization that goes around and graze
each each power plant and they give you
know guidance on how to operate this way
and they come in with giant teams the
NRC you've got a couple of people that
are there at the site at all times impo
brings in a team of 20 people and
they're like they're watching how you
take your rounds they're watching how
you're you know very thorough very
thorough yes and it's it's not once or
twice a year it's five six seven eight
times a year so you know the industry
has radically over regulated itself in a
lot of ways and people I don't think
ever hear that they only hear the horror
stories and you know one of the comments
that someone made about through my
island and this is probably the the best
way to understand how the industry is
improved is that Three Mile Island
wasn't the worst it was the one that
melted there were other plants were
probably operating because you know the
70s and 80s were we I lovingly fruit as
a wild wild west of nuclear because we
were operating and we as an industry
we're just operating yeah a lot of
industries were yeah yeah yeah and so
around this waste component right so the
hundred thousand years
you mentioned earlier 300 years what
where's how do we get that debt so the
hundred thousand years is actually based
on the half-life of plutonium-239 okay
so just literally take plutonium-239 and
half-life it out yeah you get about yeah
it's about one hundred and twenty eight
hundred and thirty thousand years or so
but yeah that's that's the typical
number the three hundred years is based
off of your fission products right so so
or your your heavy element your to call
them actin Ed's and I hate these terms
because they're so overly tech
but your heavy elements have really long
half-lives geraniums is in the billions
of years oh really yeah
okay so like longer than the planet will
be around kind of thing and then you
know plutonium's down at 24,000 years
and then when you're talking you know
your cesium and rubidium and you know
we're basically I could just aim off the
chart of nuclei or chart of a periodic
table and we could go throughout I never
memorized it right and so if uranium is
a billion years and plutonium's 120
hundred thirty thousand years how do we
get it down to hundreds of years so one
of the things is is that if we took our
spent fuel and we put it into a fast
reactor we could consume the plutonium
that exists in it we could take all that
uranium we could transmit it into
plutonium and then consume all that so
this is like the most fascinating thing
to me I told you before we got started
that Jason Williams he's been on podcast
before one of my partner's has a
business PR TI takes car tires that are
waste gets paid to take them put some in
these terminal D mania D manufactured
reactors basically brakes the car tire
down at high heat right great oil steel
carbon send gas crates power sells oil
in the steel he's using waste product to
create power what you're talking about
here with this quote unquote fast
reactor my understanding is you're going
to run uranium-235 in a fuel rod through
the traditional process there's a waste
output that waste output is still
uranium right it's just spent fuel rods
etc you can take that least uranium and
put it through a fast reactor turn the
waste uranium into plutonium and then
use that to create power separate yep
you got it man I'm gonna I told you I'm
gonna be a nuclear engineer by the end
of this so so what why can we not do
that so right now we can't do that
because there's two regulations that
were put in place in the 1970s under the
Carter Administration okay
one is is that we can't use fast
reactors in the United States and the
other at least but at the commercial
industry level in the others we can't
process our spent fuel okay so let's
take those one at a time our fast
reactors obviously they must have been
around what
Carver was president right so somebody
created them before that so Jimmy Carter
was supposed to be the first engineer on
the first nuclear-powered USS sea wolf
which is the only fast reactor that the
it was ever put on a submarine
so Jimmy Carter actually the world is so
small okay
and so when those got created why did
that administration say we can't use it
the concern is you it's that plutonium
word okay right so it was all about
weapons proliferation got it so
basically the idea that a fast reactor
takes the used geranium it turns into
plutonium immediately no we don't want
to do that because they had lead the
weapons creation but that's also not
understanding about that 80/20 blend
that I was talking about so if you use
it in a fast reactor such as the DN 800
that the Russians are using there other
people are using fast reactors yeah
there are a couple that's not many okay
but the Russians have there be an 800
which so there's a couple of terms here
so the seed which is the initial fuel
for their visits a plutonium reactor was
from weapons ok seed meaning this is the
this is the ramp 235 before it is used
of this is or this is going into the
fashion this is going into the fast
reactor it's going in as plutonium and
it's coming from
they used uranium created plutonium
before it was in a weapon now they're
taking the weapons-grade plutonium and
they're putting into the fast reactor
yep okay and so then it has let people
are a little yes about that and then and
then they've have what's called the
blanket okay so the blanket goes around
the seed and then the seed as its
operating and making power
it turns the uranium around it into
plutonium interesting and so there goes
to that process that you explained very
well six months after that reactor went
online
there was no weapons-grade material in
it remaining why because there's too
much plutonium 240 and after six months
got it so but is it absorbing it so not
all the the plutonium 239 just or the
uranium 238 absorbing a yeah because we
go back to all the plutonium 239 if it
absorbs a neutron it doesn't necessarily
always undergo a fission some of it will
absorb that Neutron and then it will
remain as plutonium-240 Wow it's crazy
to me how do they expect that to happen
yeah yes okay so like theoretically this
was supposed to happen and then they
look back months later like well what we
thought was gonna happen happened so
when they first figured it out no they
didn't expect that to happen so it was a
surprise yeah it was a surprise the
first thing when they first figured this
out but it gotta remember we're talking
30s that they were figuring this stuff
out okay okay so this isn't like even
the 80s or 90s we are talking literally
yeah we're talking as inception of
nuclear is when they when they figured
that out so okay so there's a couple of
countries that use these fast reactors
we here aren't I'm assuming that there's
efforts underway to get the approval to
use fast reactors in the United States
that I did no it's not so there is
there's a couple of companies out there
well first off the United States is
gonna build a versatile test reactor
which is to test fast fuel okay so it's
going to be designed to test fuels for
fast reactors so there is a couple of
companies one of them is probably it's
probably the biggest one that people
know about is called Terra power okay
and Terra Power has its funding source
from none other than Bill Gates I was
going to say I think I just saw this in
the Netflix documentary he was talking
about look so how does Tara power work
so today they have two different designs
one is a a sodium cooled reactor which
it all comes the coolants or what matter
with this yeah there's a molten salt
reactor but they are gonna operate in
the fast spectrum and when I say fast
it all comes to the energy of the
neutron okay so your rhenium 235
requires a thermal Neutron which means
this is a lower energy plutonium-239
requires a fast Neutron and then
everyone loves talking about thorium and
if I don't mention thorium you're gonna
have 80 million people what I'm before
we talk about thorium when you describe
fast as especially science right yeah
different makeups it reminds me of this
joke that if the government could they
would outlaw science yeah just because
you have people who usually aren't
scientist
who are making laws about science and so
if there's not an understanding it's
kind of hard to regulate an outlaw etc
when though you don't understand the
science yeah it's it's crazy it's a
thorium thorium I don't know what
thorium is I didn't know if it was a
sci-fi character or it was a something
on the periodic table but everyone was
tweeting this at me yeah well thorium
because Andrew yang has made thorium
popular okay all right so let's so Terra
Power has two separate design designs
one is that sodium based when you
describe the other is thorium it was so
basic yeah this is why nuclear gets so
confusing okay because there's coolant
there's fuel this fuel configuration
there's you know how it's just there's
so many elements that go into it
okay so taro power is do they have a
design one it's called their traveling
wave reactor that is specifically uses a
seed of uranium-235 and then depleted
uranium which you were in the Army you
know tanks use depleted uranium for
armor and four rounds right that's that
leftover stuff from the enrichment so
that's the so we could use that right we
already have a bind yep
about 10,000 years worth between
depleted uranium and our fuel if we
converted 200 percent to nuclear by the
way in the u.s. 10,000 years of energy
Wow yeah so how long science yeah go
ahead
so yeah so so and I'm not I don't have
the details and when I talk to these
companies I don't ask for the specifics
on their designs because I don't want to
get into proprietary and and I'm just
kind of evaluating them from from a
standpoint a different standpoint I know
that if you're using sodium you're gonna
go in the fast spectrum okay if you're
using a molten salt you can bury your
spectrum what you're doing whether
you're using uranium-235 plutonium or
thorium bred into uranium 233 and that's
where it gets really confusing because
uranium's involved in all of it so
thorium exists naturally it's about
three times as abundant as uranium okay
so it's basically like a uranium is just
thorium yeah I mean if you want to go
find thorium he's got to Central Park
pick up some dirt he'll find support
thorium in there
okay sounds like we just solved power
problems yeah and there's about three
quarters of million years of story among
planet Earth Wow okay yeah wait so why
is Terra power and Andrew yang why are
they stalking about thorium or using
thorium
um so thorium doesn't have the negative
connotation that plutonium and uranium
happen oh because thorium hasn't been
used to make weapons allegedly well
there was one test bomb created that
partially used uranium 233 in it so
could you make a not useful feed not so
useful weapon out of it
yeah it's extremely difficult so it's
the hardest to make weapons weapons out
of his uranium 233 so thorium is thorium
232 if you go to your periodic table it
is to below uranium is that like th th
it yeah
th and so it's 232 shot out 7th grade
science yeah so it absorbs a neutron
like the uranium does and then instead
of becoming plutonium like the rain does
it comes the radium 233 yeoreum 233 it
operate has a larger range of energies
that the that the neutrons can be at but
there's a lot of we don't have a whole
lot of experience with it okay so we
yang wants to use this cuz he just
thinks that he's like anti weapons I'm
it's safer hi I I don't I'm in a mind
read a little bit here on anti-gang I
think he's using he brought up thorium
because it sounds smart right and I mean
it is smart it's talking about advanced
things it doesn't have a negative
connotation yeah right and so it just it
pushes nuclear exactly um and to the
point where you know Lizabeth Warren who
has shut them all down literally in the
last debate was we need to keep some
nuclear reactors around so if you've
taken a hard shut all nuclear reactors
down person and soften them okay I'll
give Andrew yang a lot of credit for
that and you know I eat up and walk
around the city and every person I have
spoken to there I was concerned you know
you have that they would be anti-nuclear
I don't
the sentiment of anti-nuclear I think is
fading yeah and there's people who I see
on Twitter talking about nuclear power
power generational stuff and thorium has
never been the conversation until I
tweeted that we were gonna do this
interview and then I felt like I had the
thorium army come at ya welcome but
what's interesting to me I think is
similar to myself people are learning
more about nuclear right and they're
realizing that it isn't the Chernobyl
you know everyone's gonna die and
everyone's walking around those
protective suits on it's again it's a
scientific process their safety that is
a concern but there's also things that
are there to mitigated etc and so if we
can get reliable persistent clean energy
that's probably a pretty good thing
right so you talk about that reliable
clean safe so there was a reactor that
we built in 1965 called experimental
breeder reactor - still died out in
Idaho and they put it through a
Fukushima test on crack like it's the it
was way worse than what Fukushima had it
was a fast reactor sodium-cooled
very much like the be a hundred I talked
about earlier and much like Terra powers
design they shut off all the cooling
operate a hundred percent power
Fukushima was shut down when they lost
their when the tsunami hit alright so
the reactor drive been shut down because
the earthquake tsunami washed out their
safety systems they intentionally in
1986 with this reactor opera to get a
hundred percent power turned off her
cooling systems what happened it shut
down after 300 seconds and remained
there until they started it back up
pretty impressive that is impressive
yeah and then we've had to these are
test reactors they've had two sodium
test reactors that underwent Chernobyl
level events and they literally pulled
out the melted fuel and put a new fuel
and operated them four decades later
it's crazy so I mean and that's you know
we're talking back in the days of manual
crank control rods right so you look at
it now we have automatic protection
systems that take the human element out
of there with redundancies and yeah
you'd be amazed at the amount of so
let's go back for a second to there's
two reasons why the fast reactors aren't
used right you said the first was which
can't use fast reactors it sounds like
Tara power maybe some others are trying
to get
how are they like if Bill Gates is
investing he's obviously investing in
something but if we can't use fast
reactors what exactly is he investing in
are they doing it outside the United
States or I know that terraPower at one
point was working with China they were
gonna build some stuff out there and I
spoke with crystal aback the the CEO
about it and they were the trade war
actually shut their down their operation
out in China but with this I think that
we're about to see the regulation now
that regulation as far as using fast
reactors it's reprocessing spent fuel it
switches about every eight years so
about every eight years for some reason
it's in place then it's back and I mean
got it yeah or one will go and you know
so it's kind of just bounces back and
forth what about the regulation that
prevents us from using waste um that one
bounces with it too as well okay so
really the fast reactor is there's two
regulations we can't use waste we can
fast reactor when they go to weaken or
we can't is that political party divided
somewhat yes now one of the things is
that if we just go with the fast reactor
then we could use say a seed of
uranium-235 and then we could generate
plutonium after that and then you've got
to have to be waste but yeah ideally it
would ideally it would be yes so that we
could reduce our waste stock but or at
least not increase it right because you
know the fission products only last
about 300 years it's about one to two
percent of those that do last that long
and when you pull you pull them let's
say we used a fast reactor we used a
thorium reactor we used a pure
uranium-235 reactor and you consume two
all the fuel in it right you pull out
that way sixty percent of its not
radioactive
all right so already our way stockpile
is reduced by over half and then one to
two years later you've lost say five
percent and then it goes up over time
but a lot of those constituents are
actually useful with industrial and
medical purposes so you know you haven't
heard of radiation treatments for cancer
right that's created from the nuclear
industry then we're actually causing
radiation sickness in specific parts of
the body where the cancer cells are and
so we can you know we need that for
radiation purposes things like barium
treatment where they put a rate
act a low a low radiation chemical in
you so they can track how your body's
processing how your kidneys are working
or there's things like it's called
radiography so like you know we're in
this great building right here we're at
54th floor I think and you got all these
these these red pipes going all
throughout this building
well those welds you want to make sure
that they're they're gonna hold
especially if you know you have a fire
up here on the 54th floor right you're
really concerned about the ones on the
bottom when you have fifty four you know
floors of water on top but that's a lot
of pressure in the bottom there so we
can take it's basically like a super
x-ray to make sure there's no flaws in
the well so there's a lot of purposes
there's it's right in the middle the
periodic table called tekneq diem that
makes a great pipe coating but we can't
generate it now it doesn't exist
naturally we have to generate at nuclear
power so there's all sorts of things
that if we could reprocess the waste
they're gonna benefits do their benefits
and one things I like talking about is
it if I went to a u.s. reactor anywhere
in the u.s. right now and I could
magically change it from being a thermal
reactor to being a fast reactor that
fuel instead of lasting four and a half
years would last 500 because why because
we use so little of it got it the fast
rector is more efficient with the use of
the fuels yeah because we use a hundred
percent of the uranium and that would be
less pressure on the uranium mining
business right because now we don't have
to dig up as much of it and at least we
can extend the use of what we can dig up
yeah we have we have about a quarter
million years of uranium if we use fast
reactors thousand if we use thermal can
we create these nuclear power generation
or power plants just like we have them
on submarines and aircrafts one of the
questions I saw in mine was can we use
it to let's say power this building or
an apartment complex or a car or like
kind of smaller scale type activities or
are we just not there on the science
side well so the US Department of Energy
is testing what they call micro reactors
okay what's that so it's a reactor on a
an extremely small scale so we're so to
give you an idea the the actual size of
a submarine
react the actual physical reactor itself
is only the size of a 55 gallon trash
can really yeah
Wow now that's not including the turbine
ELISA but that's just the power the
actual where the heat is generated is
only about the size of 55 gallon trash
can
Wow there are micro reactors that are
being designed that are literally the
size of a Charmin extra jumbo roll of
toilet paper Wow
so now is what they want to do with
those put them on space probes okay
space force you need some power in terms
and we're gonna get the space but so
this is probably the idea that if you
send a probe out you if it needs fuel
that fuel will eventually run out you
have to put a human there to somehow
regulate the fuel usage in some cases
and either the human will die or you'll
run out of fuel and you can't get it
back so if you have nuclear you can get
much more life and power out of it yeah
that nuclear you used to a lot of these
probes that we've sent out right they
don't they're operating on very very low
power levels yeah you know they're going
way deep you know very deep and you can
send these things out and if you're
talking a small reactor like that it
could last for you know two three four
hundred years that way the other thing
going back to the waste is it there's
something called nuclear batteries okay
so as those those those fission products
decay they release radiation you can
actually cause that radiation to
interact much in the similar way that a
a solar panel works okay you can have it
generate electricity so if you took
radioactive waste that lasts for 300
years you could probably have a battery
that they're gonna over all the you know
they're gonna degrade over time much
like solar panels well but um you know
you could have a say a battery that
lasts to 300 you know to 250 years that
you've been a design and build what's
the difference was so much of people
talking about Fusion vs. fission nuclear
fusion fu si I think it was what what is
that so fission we're talking about the
splitting of atoms Fusion is the
combining of atoms going to that that
tritium thing man I really
go back to the textbook okay so the
nuclear fusion if you're not splitting
the atom or what exactly do you do so
you're you're taking so typically the
the way that they're like in the Sun
it's typically a helium-3 in a deuterium
atom I think that it fuses okay to
create the energy that's how most the
Sun is actually making its power through
fusion but here on planet earth we would
use deuterium and tritium that's just
hydrogen to 103 is just bad soup feds
forms of hydrogen and so you would
basically if you used like and I'm not
smart on fusion so there's no worry
about the Twitter trolls are yeah
they're way smarter
they've got thorium and they've got a
yeah so on so you can you know using
whatever process and you know it's kind
of a you know it's kind of a unicorn of
the nuclear world is fusion which is
what would be the benefit of using
fusion rather than fission um well when
you shut a fusion reaction down you
don't have that 2k heat that heats is
you wouldn't have to put the spent fuel
rod in yeah there we go wrong but the
only problem with that is that fusion
requires vision because you have to
generate large quantities of tritium for
it yep which going back to Fukushima
they were worried about their yeah and
the vending yeah so and you generate
that in nuclear reactor has anybody done
nuclear fusion
any level of scale even in a test type
environment well the first test route in
the Marshall Islands called you know
place called Bikini Atoll where we
called the h-bomb
yes we have done fusion it's its first
test we're done with nuclear weapons we
have gotten nuclear fusion to work it
just hasn't been we haven't done it on a
scale that's able to generate enough
power to keep it self-sustaining without
you know basically producing more power
than it needs okay so the initial
attempts at nuclear fusion we're all
weapons related
same thing with nuclear power cover yep
so basically when we did that the h-bomb
and and all that office again scary for
some people all right but the the
challenge there
like is we create too much power well I
mean you won regular unregulated amount
of well it's problem is not necessarily
doable if the problem is is that it's
making the reaction sustained right so
right it's with the the fission you've
got that you you split the atom
it creates neutrons well in this case
you have to you fuse the atom it creates
energy which is gonna drive outward but
you got to keep all that stuff together
so that you can keep your atoms close
enough and I'm Way not next yes I'm sure
there's some troll right now who's going
out there when he's got it all wrong and
he's probably right and this is my
understanding I bet people will tweet at
us and yeah I'm sure yeah fusion I I
actually I actually like when they tweet
back because then I actually do learn
now they don't really say it in the
nicest way but yeah he'll learn all
right so last thing I want to talk about
is I usually ask people about aliens on
the podcast I don't want to write any
ins because as I was thinking through
this one of the things that I haven't
spent all the time talking about podcast
but fascinates me is this idea of
manufacturing in space right so if you
think about can we send a bunch of stuff
up to space and is it easier faster
cheaper whatever to do manufacturing in
space that got me thinking as I was
preparing for this why if you know has
anyone looked at it and if not why not
doing some of the nuclear power
generation in space eat whether it's
testing whether it's some sort of study
state etc have people thought about that
have is the environment it's the
scientific you know components different
what's going on with kind of the the
intersection of space and nuclear power
other than you know the fact that we
we're testing it to go deploy it
I don't know testing it meaning like the
space bro yes but yet power plants for
the space probes and and deep you know
pay their colony size for they get me to
put a colony on the moon or on Mars you
need energy and their nuclear is going
to be the method for that oh really
yeah so that's that's part of the
testing for all that stuff is to and
this is you know we're rudimentary
testing levels you have this down but
but there it would be testing of nuclear
power
to power colonization on Mars or the
moon yeah because then you know it's
once again it's a small compact abundant
energy right you know if I can make you
say yeah if I can make it reacted a lot
you know right the you know fits in a
toilet paper roll that can power B for a
while right compare that to a solar
panel where I gotta get how many of
those things it's a weight cost weight
savings thing so there's a lot of that
as clean as aliens will appreciate it
being clean energy so if you want to
talk nuclear in aliens there is belief
that the Tunguska explosion and early
1900s in Russia was caused by an alien
nuclear weapons so there's a nuclear
weapon today what what is this the
Tunguska explosion in Russia what is
that there was a big giant explosion and
again like the night early 1900s okay
I've never heard of it yeah it looks
like a giant but it was right in the
middle of Siberia and so there's beliefs
that you know what are the you know the
ancient aliens theories or whatever is
that it was a it wasn't actually an an
alien that decided to test a nuclear
weapon and Russia's backyard I actually
had a researcher his name is Bruce
Fenton come on he's a ancient alien
researcher and I could see the threads
of like 60 70 percent of it and then
there was some that just and I told him
I said you lost me on that one yeah the
natural belief is it was an asteroid got
in the early nineteen hundred's yeah
yeah it just to me I guess there's pros
and cons right if I had to conceptually
think about it makes a lot of sense hey
let's go test nuclear power for the
column potential colonies on other
planets or on the moon but if it's
lighter
could it be cheaper you know is there
different whether it's minerals or
components or whatever in space II that
you could actually do nuclear in space I
guess the hard part would be how do you
get it back right in terms of if you're
doing power generation or if you want it
back yeah is there a way to action bring
back I mean it could just be that you've
run a you know because I mean the space
shuttles mmm rest in peace you know they
they actually were powered by hydrogen
and oxygen
interesting yeah so there are fuel their
fuel cells if they use high
in oxygen - as their air fuel and so if
you think about it right we could use
hydrogen oxygen generation at a nuclear
power plant as our method to you know
shuttle things back and forth between
say a nuclear-powered space station and
then that way you know instead of having
you know we're using nuclear power but
reason to create chemical energy yep it
goes into the carbon capture and so if
we're talking about going up the side by
going down why don't we just create
nuclear power plants in the earth or
like under the sea in terms of so think
about we're willing to obviously
submerse them with submarines etc right
so we've figured out in some form or
fashion how to do it on a smaller scale
would there be either mitigation of the
waste argument or some other advantage
to building a nuclear power plant down
inside the crust of the earth or inside
of a mountain or something or under the
sea um I mean there's there's really you
know you could put them basically
anywhere you just need some kind of
whatever your cooling sources is a way
to get the power yes yeah one the big
thing is is that when you're talking any
kind of a steam engine like that you
waste two-thirds of your heat so you got
to do some of that heat so that's the
big thing right and you know we use you
whether it's the ocean lakes rivers or
you know in the weird case and I'll
bring it up again is you know palaver
day out in Arizona it literally uses
Phoenix's waste water they treat the
treated sewage goes out to Palo Verde
and that's what they used to cool their
their plants out there it's crazy yeah
what a last question for you what are
you most excited about over the next
let's call 20 years in nuclear power um
so I'm gonna give you that and bytes
okay so I'm excited for 2021 when local
unit three comes online it's the first
nuclear reactor that's gonna new
construction nuclear reactor to be built
that's super exciting 2022 new scale
breaks ground in Idaho to build their 12
unit facility called u amps same designs
as older ones or these this is
these are small modular reactors are
gonna be factory built so that's that's
new and exciting I think they're looking
I think Canada is looking to have a Gen
4 molten salt reactor design built by
2027 so there's a lot of really really
cool stuff coming down the line with all
this so I'm super excited and that's not
even any day any Bitcoin mining um you
know what what's wrong with a Bitcoin
you know it's funny I was gonna wait to
the very end dad yeah cuz I know nothing
about Bitcoin mining really I know
nothing I you know I I literally I got
into Bitcoin because of Eric Finn my man
I met him at an event and he said he's
creating this app so as soon as he had
it I got it I started buying Bitcoin and
I've had I've heard about there's
literally a nuclear power plant that
they a couple of workers got in trouble
for Bitcoin mined in Russia I think
right yeah yeah Russia Ukraine I
remember but I literally I don't even
know what Bitcoin mining is so I'll give
you the two seconds think of you need
computational power okay you essentially
solve a problem mm-hmm we solve that
problem you've mined a block when you
get that there's a mining reward right
very overgeneralization of how it works
good in order to do this computational
heavy work you have essentially hardware
that has software on it and you need
power to run it the largest input cost
to mining is the power cost so think of
it kind of like a traditional data
center but rather than me putting CPUs
into a data center I plug power in I've
space i buy CPUs and then I rent my CPU
computing power out to a customer
okay now what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
get power I'm gonna plug it into a space
I'm gonna put either GPUs or Asics so
different types of computers and I'm
gonna not rent that computing power out
to a customer I'm basically gonna use it
to run the software for these networks
those networks will then pay me a very
predictable transparent way so data
center for crypto currencies basically
okay easy description because of that if
you need low cost power what do people
do take a look for renewable and
so what you see around the world is you
see a lot of hydro you see a little bit
of solar not so much you see a little
bit of wind not so much but you see
excess hydro now you're starting to see
people go down to like Texas flare gas
the business I told you that my partner
runs a PRT I they take that caller tire
and that output of power actually used a
mine Bitcoin and aetherium so they're
using a self-contained power generation
right that's vertically integrated to a
cryptocurrency mind etc naturally as you
think through that well what has
persistent power it's cheap is clean etc
nuclear my whole fascination with this
was I had not heard of until the guys in
Russia I think it was anyone using
nuclear power to mine Bitcoin and so I
was like let me go learn about nuclear
first before I even start with with a
Bitcoin mining but I guess it's not
something that's been talked about in
there and the power community really
well and then what's fascinating is is
that this is why you'd put them up north
okay is it self cool because yeah well
and your nuclear is more efficient the
colder the water oh interesting yeah
machines are actually they stay cool one
of the the other large input cost is
basically how do you cool the machines
yeah stick them in Texas it's much more
difficult than yeah Iceland yeah yeah
Icelander you know say happen that Yukon
or whatever but you're up in Alaska
right you could use your nuclear power
plant for your source of energy and then
you've got natural cooling from huh so
the nuclear were just power in general
right so if a company was to create self
generate power or whether it's through
car tires or anything else they can
usually sell it into the grid depending
on you know with the location etc what's
called three to five cents right is kind
of the general take there then it's
getting sold to consumers at eight nine
ten twelve cents whatever it is you
could take that same power in the same
environment and generate 30 or 40 cents
in terms of mining cryptocurrency so
it's a pretty material you know step up
in the revenue you can generate from
that power creation I don't know the
economics of nuclear power but my guess
is that if you're able to divert some
you know percentage of the power
generation or excess power generation
right that isn't able to be stored and
you were able to mine Bitcoin or some
other cryptocurrency with it you could
actually make it incredibly profitable
because that power is persistent as
clean as cheap etc yeah so I not heard
megawatt plant typically makes about a
million dollars a day
oh you're that's and that's profit
that's pennies compared to what they
would make money but yeah that's crazy
you know it's it if we talk to whoever
owns that 900 megawatt facility they
might shut down or stop selling it into
the into the grid yeah
Wow that's you know it's funny because I
found this weird partnership you know
you guys like you're reaching out to me
and a lot of the crypto guys are
reaching out to me talking about and now
that you've given me the you know the
forward one on on Bitcoin or crypto
mining it makes a lot of sense and I
know there's a large power thing the
other organ is a or the other group of
people that are movers and shakers that
are reaching out to me is the cannabis
industry oh right now what's funny is
that if you work a nuclear if you pop on
a drug test to include marijuana you
can't work on nuclear for five more
years
so it's this really weird thing I'm in
right now where it's like you know these
these you know these guys for the
cannabis industry are reaching out and
I'm like this is like this weird
conglomeration well on it and my cousin
is actually kind of a mover and shaker
and I should probably get him in touch
with you cuz you probably think find him
fascinating talking about all his stuff
with cannabis but you know they're in
that same type of thing where they look
and they go renewables you start working
because they want lights on 24/7 365 -
in their grow beds and they're working
on if you talk go back to Bill Gates and
he's you know whether you believe global
warming or not you know the the two
biggest things you need to work on is
soil and energy
all right well nuclear solves the energy
aspect and then the cannabis industry
literally is taking it upon themselves
to work on things like hydroponics and
aquaponics to basically get you know
crops into say a vertical farm that you
can run lights on 24/7 365 you got a
have the temperatures just right and you
can do that with large amounts of energy
a nuclear and it's it's just fascinating
it to me is you get what tend to be
technologists now are going to these
industries and what they start to do is
they start to look at vertical
integration right and so they're
realizing that just like in software
where I used to have one layer of a
technology stack if I can vertically
integrate there's a lot of cost savings
efficiencies etc what I've seen on
multiple occasions across industries is
in anything that requires some level of
power generation you're starting to see
this interest in vertical integration
now the difference is software's one
thing the ability to understand how to
grow weed you know built build up
facility and also do power generation
those are pretty different skill sets
and so you've got to build teams or
partnerships whatever um the nice thing
in crypto is if you're into computers
and mining etc you actually have a
pretty good understanding of power
generation and really from an economic
standpoint how do I find cheapest power
where is it how to hook it up to these
computers and so I've heard a lot of
people doing all kinds of crazy stuff
never heard of nuclear until the one
group got in trouble obviously yeah but
but it just seems like it would be a
natural extension of what they're
already doing but but I just hadn't
heard anything yeah you know it's it's
it's fascinating because I'm sure your
follower of Scott Adams like I am and he
talked about the floating city and I saw
that and it's literally the first thing
that popped in my mind was company
called Thor Khan that their their entire
design is a floating power module so you
could literally you know build build
this this power plant that's floats
right with your floating city and I mean
you know they're they're you know not a
very big size wise but they put out five
hundred megawatts of power very large
amount of power on a relatively small
item you've got the ocean which you get
unlimited cooling the concerns of you
know they're designed actually safe from
meltdown can use any kind of fuel you
want it to and then you know the fact is
is that if you were concerned about
you've got an ocean right there you
could literally decoupling from your
your city and tow it away right and
you've got all the water you need power
generation if you can do it in a either
modulated way or in a mobile way is very
very powerful yeah that's crazy so well
we'll talk more maybe we'll find a
nuclear power plant and set up some some
Bitcoin mine yeah sounds good to me
listen I really appreciate you coming to
do this where can that we're gonna be
we'll find you online or more about what
you're working on um so I typically am
on Twitter and my handle is at sub Hyder
cuz I was on submarine so it's s UB s CH
any ITER or you can also go to my
website which is www.hyken.com to join
is we will definitely have to do this
again is super super fun for me
approches fun too Thanks